in der ganzen szene sind 80 prozent den
alkoholika drogenabhängig depressiv oder
am tablett problem ohne alles zusammen
oder alles zusammen
multi polylux aber du bist raus gekommen
du bist total happy dass ja ich bin
jetzt seit vier heraus und bist du denn
auch happy dass es mit dem biss was
jetzt macht stimmungssänger ich sag mal
so wird ja der ein oder andere kollege
ich habe spaß dabei
ich liebe es ich liebe es und die
meisten bis der körper oktober noch
nicht weiß was ich so mache aber ich
habe an die letzte hatten die 200 grenze
erreicht dann auftreten im jahr und ich
erreiche im land es sowas schon mal
sogar 200 mal im jahr tritt darauf ja
nicht nur mallorca wer muss wann tritt
sein wird jahr 200 arbeitstage also auf
arbeitszeit gerechnet du arbeitest eben
ich weiß was macht manchmal ein paar
auftritt am tag wie waren diese
wahnsinns auf mallorca 21 33
trotzdem singt ein bisschen das ist aber
meine stimme sonntagsmorgens höre ich
mich so an
es ist wirklich harte arbeit aber man
muss sich lieben und leben wenn man es
nur so runter holt manch andere kollegen
wollte jetzt keine namen nennen
dann funktioniert das nicht oder nur
begrenzt und ich will ja lange nicht
erhalten
aber wenn sie mich jetzt fragen würdest
entscheide dich musik oder schon gern
rein konnte jetzt ich liebe beides und
auch wenn die alle kollegen mich
belächeln die ernst weil er
theater-schauspieler also die lacht
michael aussagen wie kann man denn so
was machen für ihn damit mein geld ich
habe spaß dabei und ich liebe das
verhältnis zum publikum
ich bin absolut davon ich bin im
volksmund zum antreten
wenn ich dann so manche kollegen sehe
auf der bühne die machen ihr ding gegen
noch nichtmals runter verteilt
autogramme ich mein letztes minister ja
mindestens runter geht oder so zu den
leuten und hallo sagt man von den leuten
leben wir und die haben wir das zu
verdanken dass wir da stehen wo wir
stehen
aber es ist ein knallhartes geschäft
alice kinder lacht das ist so wenn die
leute sich mich verständigen
mai macht über 200 auftritte mehr
mallorca bulgarien sonnenstand bulgarien
goldstrand südtirol österreich schweiz
unterwegs ist das eigentlich so ein klub
ich habe das video gesehen hier aus bonn
mit michael wendler hat sich gerade
wieder vertragen weil hier vertragen
roboter worüber habt euch gestritten
wollte auch der wollte habe ich wollte
die herren vom nachnamen nein wenn auch
nicht hatten ein privates problem was
ich jetzt hier nicht willig breit treten
möchte ich mir andere ausgesprochen das
hat mir gut getan ich glaub ich auch
sehr gut getan mittlerweile telefonieren
wir auch wieder
mittlerweile besucht uns auch wieder im
grunde märz kann einer sagen
im herzen ist ein eigentlich kein
verkehrter aber wenn man tief bohrt
viele schichten dort aber so ist das
eigentlich ein netter und jetzt ist
einmal richtig gut die nase gefallen was
ändern
ich glaube ich könnte aber gut wenn so
ein kreis von leuten ihr trefft euch
dann wahrscheinlich wenn das eben wenn
man dazu in dem bändchen sind aber
yorker unterwegs wie so peter wackel der
funktioniert noch mal in deutschland
nicht und das dj ötzi helene fischer und
ihre geht wahrscheinlich tritt zusammen
auf und abends auch noch ein privaten
club zusammen oder an den einfach steht
man sich mehr mit anderen weniger aber
wenn man erfolg hat also in dieser
branche kommt einem der anderen nichts
mit butterbrot und das ist schon sehr
hart muss man auch einmal lernen mit
umzugehen